let's go to our next caller from the
seven-one-seven area code caller from
seven-one-seven can you hear me what's
your name and where you're calling from
hi my name is Zach from Lancaster
Pennsylvania
great what's on your mind Zach well I
think it was last week
annachi Coates came out with a really
good article called Donald Trump the
first white president and I was
wondering if you had read that and how
do you feel about the conclusions he
draws from I did not read it what what
conclusions are drawn that Donald Trump
is the first president to be elected by
running on being white you know he ran
on every policy that Obama had we have
to go against it he sort of galvanized
his his followers to you know I can't
find the words I think I get what you're
saying yeah I mean I think there's a
couple issues there one is yes Trump has
run and has legislated significantly on
the idea of Obama did it oh well then
let's undo it now just because Obama was
black that doesn't necessarily mean that
any opposition to Obama policies by
Trump is sort of running on or to white
people or on whiteness necessarily being
the key word but nobody can deny that
you have seen white identity movements
and we could list them I won't but you
know what most of the many of them are
Donald Trump has sort of coalesced
activated and galvanized white identity
movements in a way that presidents
haven't presidential candidates haven't
for a very very long time now
the first white president there was a
time when the idea of a non-white
president was laughable and really the
idea of even needing to appeal but to
anybody but white people was also sort
of an unnecessary in American politics
so I think in the modern era maybe
there's an argument to be made but for a
long time
presidential elections were by and for
white people so I don't know I'd have to
read the article but it sounds
interesting it it's very good he
actually starts from these the beginning
of America if you want to call it that
but he talks about how the serving class
in the early beginnings of America would
would would argue that they would never
like to be called servant so they would
never like to be called these sorts of
diminutive terms because they always
looked at that there being one class
below them and I definitely suggest this
article for the audience is very long
read I think it's going to be part of
his new book but but very good it's in
the Atlantic very good all right thank
you very much appreciate the call Zack
always great to hear from you